I think that was most of the work the
pictures not too hard but there was one
other thing we could have done there was
a different way we could have gone
balanced I suggest it might have been
simpler the first thing you said what
was the very very very first step you
suggested to me after I wrote down the
question the first thing you told me to
do is differentiate that's not a bad
idea it worked out okay is there
anything we could have done before we
differentiated to make any of this
easier this this some particular graph
they've given us right it's not just any
graph you have some tools to work with
this do you recognize this you could
have used the other angle with you
didn't have to it was okay we don't work
out any easier if we did auxilary angle
would it been easy I just posed the
question to you what does your instinct
say if you have a guess instinct might
say yes because auxilary angle turns two
functions into one that's that's
generally a better fit to work with
right what is the auxilary angle for
this this is what you got
big bad big big thing with it you've got
you've got four forms to choose from
okay in this particular one two of them
are better than the other two which ones
would you choose you could choose the
way the way I look at it is causes first
because it's first so I would choose
cars right and there's a plus here the
expansion for cause that gives me a plus
is minus I could do that that would work
however as you notice when you're adding
two things it doesn't matter what order
you add them in right so sine is first
then I would say sine and the expansion
force either gives me a plus here is X
plus alpha okay so either is fine you're
still getting acute angle for either
this let's go in this one okay can you
how did we get ah where did it all come
from
it is equal to two but why wait where
does that number just where does it come
from it comes from the square root of a
square plus B Smith doesn't it yeah okay
so R is going to be equal to in this
case how did I get alpha
I can say 10 alpha is equal to which one
which one I will get this remember
now by the way that's that's fine
okay but you have to be careful I can
only use ten alpha because I've chosen
the right form right when can you not
use ten alpha or maybe I should say when
you have to be more careful about ten
are five under what circumstances do you
remember if they told you for instance
and the question can if they told you to
put it into this form what's going to
happen to alpha these determine - that
alpha is not going to be a cute anymore
that's kind of why we chose these two
forms because but here you lose the fact
that is your angle acute or obtuse or
reflux what is it ten doesn't tell you
okay it's not enough information because
tan being positive you could be this one
or this one you don't know right so if I
did want to know which quadrant it's in
without a shadow of a doubt what would I
have to do I can't use your turn what do
I do
you've got to go back to this expansion
you've got to know if your sign air
because if you do the side of both of
them then you'll be able to tell
unambiguously which quadrant you'll be
in any way don't turn this into a lesson
on exhilarate go because we're trying to
calculate what's the angle that matches
up with this this is plan six isn't it
okay right
so therefore Y is two sides X plus six
so what's the first derivative
two cars down this is chain rule but it
just so happens that the derivative of
the inside function is one that's nice
was that easier to differentiate I think
so the second derivative which by the
way is exactly what you ought to expect
because we kind of concluded that
already didn't we just saying now who
would fly the stationary points of a guy
like this you compare it I'm not going
to do it on the board because I think
you know how to do this but you can pare
back to this I don't know maybe you
would prefer like that because then you
don't have to muck around with the
domain and be careful with that kind of
thing saying this I kind of like it
though we didn't tell you to do auxilary
angle which is why you might just
straight to dare and it was fine okay
but it's your interest sometimes to
choose to do so because it will simplify
the question for you
okay easier make the differentiation
easier as well okay so just be mindful
as you go through these questions
they're not necessarily gonna say use
general solution for this but it might
be the best way to go it might be the
best to thwart okay